I was really going back and forth about
whether to mention this because the
argument could be made that by talking
about what I'm about to talk about
I am propping up or giving exposure to
ideas that should be kept totally out of
the public debate but I think what I'm
about to share with you is so pernicious
so dangerous that it's actually
important to be aware that it's going on
because of how vile it is all right
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones of
Infowars Fame claimed on a recent
broadcast that the shooting in Las Vegas
the biggest mass shooting in American
history was perpetrated by someone who
was connected to a member of or in
cahoots with an Tifa the left-wing
anti-fascist movement here is a clip
from Alex Jones's program the news is
lying
FBI HRT did the hit on the guy and they
found an taifa information in the room
and photos of the woman in the Middle
East so he did not kill himself the FBI
hostage rescue team killed him because
he was firing on them so he did not want
to be taken alive and reportedly he did
it and it was Andy for crap everywhere
and other things I'm not supposed to
mention that is directly from the
hostage rescue team vile disgusting but
completely predictable completely
predictable there were others also
posting similarly deranged ideas an
anonymous anti-semitic account posted a
picture of the shooter and wrote that he
was a left-wing anti-trump and Tifa
Democrat in the same in a reply that
same user wrote that paddock looks like
a Jew that was retweeted 1,800 times as
of yesterday another Twitter user tried
linking padic the shooter to former
President Barack Obama as well as an
Tifa Steven paddock apparently
representing the retired plane owning
wealthy wing of an Tifa if you are to
believe this we have a really really
disturbed trumpet
who has been watching our show for a
long time now this isn't a troll we know
for a variety of reasons I'm just going
to identify her by her first name of
Colleen she sent a series of emails in
the last couple of days but the gist of
it is she thinks it's a false flag as
she wrote responding to our coverage of
the Vegas shooting another false flag
look into it all done to take guns away
note that nobody is saying Trump wants
to take guns away that is proof that it
doesn't matter what happens these people
will say this under Obama they were all
false flag shootings that Obama was
involved in to take guns away of course
no guns were actually taken away record
gun sales under Obama under Trump
they're also false flags to take guns
away but now it's some other entity
that's perpetrating the false flex Trump
isn't involved because he's not the guy
trying to take guns away this is the
sick nature of it right and if we point
this out we hear that oh no but David
that's part of the destruction the deep
state or whoever were the Illuminati the
trilateral commission build the birds I
don't even know who it is at this point
they do the same thing under Republican
and Democratic administrations because
that's how you create plausible
deniability if you say to Jones
Alex Jones Alex no one else is
corroborating what you supposedly have
been told he will say well that's
because my contact is the only person
actually telling the truth
so the common thread going through all
these conspiracy theorists is that the
beliefs are unfalsifiable if you ask the
de feasibility question right okay I've
heard your hypothesis what would change
your mind what would make you believe
that you're wrong you will not get an
answer they believe that they have
already figured out that they are
correct so we can't work with these
people right we can't work with people
who believe this stuff to improve the
country I've said it before we need to
work around them we need to be working
on get out the vote we need to be
circumventing these people because they
are pulled into this stuff in such a way
that either you know if it's Alex Jones
I still believe that part of it is just
profit motive
I'm not saying this to defend Jones I
think that even pretending to have these
ideas is dangerous I when I met him he
seemed like he played a character like
the conspiracy stuff as a character to
make money maybe it's not either way
it's not a defense of Jones but for a
lot of his cronies or the people that
follow him this stuff is very very real
so we cannot work with these people and
this is something that somehow someway
has to be rooted out or at least become
so marginalized that its impact is
effectively zero and sadly right now the
impact and influence of this type of
garbage is more than zero and we need to
be aware of it and we're gonna have to
work around it together and there's a
discussion happening on our reddit
discussion forum actually about this
right now and you can participate in
that at david pakman.com slash read it
new sponsor today for the David Pakman
show today's episode made possible by
Blue Sky binary forex trading is a huge
space
millions of traitors around the world
80% of those traders lose money in forex
and usually it's some combination of
lacking the appropriate knowledge maybe
relying on others like traders or auto
trading platforms instead of themselves
getting emotional taking big risks maybe
not following proper money management
rules and blue sky binary offers their
education course and they are a leading
financial education and tech company
specifically focused on forex they've
got senior traders with actual trading
experience and they offer a really well
structured and self-paced course in
forex to help with all of the above the
course includes video on-demand online
tests one-to-one sessions and access to
their community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and our viewers
and listeners can get a one-week free
trial at blue sky binary.com
slash david not only does it include
access to their training platform but
also you get a session with a senior
trader to go over the basics of forex
trading afterwards it is 19
a month if you want to continue you can
stop and resume at any point
check it out blue sky binary.com /d avi
D